hello everyone and welcome to the
definitely the most requested game from
yesterday's uh ftx wrote to miami
preliminaries it's shakira mamiyara
versus richard rapport it's a game from
round three and it's uh quite an amazing
one as it features the king's indian
defense and a very very rare line that
occurs very early on in the game now
another thing that's interesting is that
the rapport just finished playing in the
candidates so you know that he's
extremely well prepared and whoever you
know comes up against him will
will very likely have a very very hard
time playing against him uh but uh
that's exactly why this game is so
awesome i'm not going to spoil too much
uh let's dive straight into it mamidarov
has the white pieces and he opens with
the d4 knight to f6 by rapport c for g6
going for the king's indian defense
knight the c3 and bishop to g7 so the
normal stuff uh g3 preparing to think it
to the light core bishop
castles and bishop to g2 and here robert
plays knight to c6 and rapport says uh i
came prepared uh extremely well as
mamidyarov plays this line quite a lot
he played it against fanfares he played
it against magnus cross and he played
against alexander grishouk but what's
interesting is that um medev never
actually won a game playing this opening
with white against the absolute top
level competition uh so he decides to
deviate from his usual moves and he just
plays h3 and h3 is a not a new move but
uh in top level just completely
unexplored
and after rapport plays e6 it is now
already as of move six that we have a
completely new game so whatever rapper
prepared for uh mama darva probably uh
went out to the window when uh mamido
played this h3 move so here we have e4
grabbing the full center and now uh you
might expect something like d6 or d5 but
uh rapper plays e5 he puts pressure on
the d4 pawn
and he advis he invites
mamiyar to advance the pawn all the way
to d5 so d5 knights the d4 and now
knight to f3 attacking the knight here
twice but also going after the e5 pawn
so what do you play here well you could
uh play something like knight back to e8
it's been tried before not tried before
but the idea is a known one uh the
knight in some lines of the king's
indian goes to e8 and then the bishop
covers the e5 pawn and also uh by extent
the the d4 square is covered twice but
here we have c5 by rapport
and now what do you play here okay it's
an offer of a trade so knight captures
an e5 knight captures an e4 we have
knight captures an e4 and the bishop
captures an e5 and here mommy thereof
just castles the safety we have d6 and
now bishop to g5 attacking the queen and
the queen to c7 here things already
start
getting very very interesting queen to
b6 is a bit safer but it's hard to
realize such things when playing rapid
chess and here we have rook to e1 uh
queen to c7 can be exploited with a move
like f4 and it's definitely a move you
want to play but um uh the the real idea
is that after let's say
bishop to g7 knights the f6 check of
course you do not want to give up your
dragon you're going to play king to h8
and now comes this very very tricky
queen to a queen to e1 move uh with the
idea of g4 and queen to h for going
after the h7 pawn it would be very very
hard for black to defend this but okay
if you don't notice this is a rapid
chess it's uh quite a lot to the spot so
rook to e1 by mommy darov and now pawn
to f5 challenging the knight here knight
back to c3 and the bishop to d7 just
continuing development uh bishop to e7
now attacking the rook but uh
doesn't really matter as the d6 pawn is
defended so rook to f7 uh and now uh
comes the idea behind mamidarov's bishop
to e7 it seems like a weird move because
after the rook moves you're going to
have to move it back then we can double
up on the file or play whatever but the
idea is rook captures an e5 this is what
momodaro had in mind so now you have to
capture back d captures on e5 and now d6
now defending the bishop on e7 attacking
the queen and also opening up this
diagonal for the light square bishop so
here mamadar's bishop pair is definitely
uh you know a a monstrous one so queen
to b6 putting pressure on the b pawn and
now not bishop to d5 uh going for
uh going for this wouldn't really be all
that impressive because we will happily
play queen captures and b2 and you don't
really care if bishop captures an f7
king captures an f7 it's uh you know
perfectly fine there's not all that much
to worry about it's black who is pushing
with the knight here with the queen uh
the bishop is coming to c6 so it would
be mamidarov who would be defending here
so here instead knight to d5 attacking
the queen and forcing the queen to
capture on b2 now queen captures on b2
and now rook to b1
we have queen captures on a2 and now
only now knight to f6 check and now you
have to give up the rogue because the
bishop falls for free so rook captures
an f6 bishop captures an f6 and now you
have to be extremely careful uh and the
move you want to play here to avoid
total annihilation is bishop the c6
which makes sense you want to counter
the strong light square bishop as the
dark square bishop already controls this
diagonal you do not want the light
square bishop here on this diagonal
however rapport says all right that's
really not not all that big of a deal i
can always put my king to f8 and he
played bishop to a4 and we've reached
the position from the thumbnail but now
the problem is uh rapport is completely
busted maderov actually has a forced
checkmate in nine moves and it is truly
a spectacular one so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this
incredible idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you are a true master
of wielding dual bishops and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is bishop the d5 with check but the
first movie is easy to find uh i have no
no doubt all of you found this one the
hard move is the next one king to f8
and now comes rook captures on b7 that's
the good stuff we sacrifice the queen
and there really isn't a better move
than to capture the queen but uh if you
don't capture the queen what are you
even doing here it's uh like you you
know you you were caught completely off
guard you are oblivious as to what is
happening on the board so here you just
have to capture the queen and uh you
know go with the flow so here bishop
captures on d1 was played now rook to f7
with check king the e8 king the g8
doesn't help if came to g8 then we just
deliver one check here and now if king
goes here then rook to g this checkmate
now because it will be checked from the
bishop and also if you go here then rook
to g8 will again be checkmate as all of
these squares are covered by the bishops
but in the game after rook to f7 check
king the e8 was played but it doesn't
help all that much because now momidarov
can just push a pawn and deliver
checkmate pawn to d7 check and this is
now also checkmate as the bishops uh are
are doing a great work here and the king
is in check so of course the game ends
here so truly a spectacular game uh only
26 moves uh for mamidor to deliver a
checkmate with a pawn on d7 and you can
see just how uh dangerous it is when you
when you try to prepare something for
for a top elite player a former 2800
member like shakhtar mahmoud uh he he
just surprised you with a move like h3
and uh you know you are you are
completely in the dark and you know uh
good things happen for him
uh so yeah incredible game thank you for
suggesting it definitely the the
highlight of the first day if you guys
have any other of uh favorites you
should use hashtag suggestion i will try
to try to cover as many of them as
possible uh but uh until then uh or
rather after that we are continuing with
day two as we are expecting more great
games uh to happen today uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh always be careful when facing the
king's indian but also have something
prepared when facing the king's indian
uh i would like to thank kalman d valar
morghulis stephen abrams nagarjuna
pongotti and david bacon for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event uh until it finishes uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day